welcome back to new rockstars this is
the big question the show that gives you
too much information
about how to kill an unkillable marvel
hero
until it just becomes downright boring
because if your deadpool death
is something you pray for i'm eric voss
here with me today
is tommy bechtold hey man hey he's not
the only one praying for death eric
[Laughter]
don't you dare pray for it i'm gonna be
praying against death for you
so that it counteracts your vote in the
name of jesus
putting crystals out all over to ward
off that
brain for death to take a holiday she's
earned it yes um
here's the deal we've gotten
confirmation that deadpool 3 is head of
the mcu with ryan reynolds and
a script is in the works from the
molyneux sisters and when we last saw
deadpool
in deadpool 2 all the way back in 2018
the
film featured a memorable suicide
montage even
a near-death experience that ended as a
kind of logan parody
yeah that was then followed by a share
scored
time travel montage oh god we gotta
re-watch that movie yes but now
wade wilson is crossing over into a
cinematic universe that takes death
very very seriously yeah i'd say so what
is our big question this week yeah eric
well
with these new settings and surroundings
i need to know is deadpool
immortal and if not how do you kill him
i'm about to do to you
what liv biscuit did to music in the
late 90s yeah a great
great question wade wilson became
deadpool
when his weapon x experimentation that
was trying to
rate him of cancer at least that's what
they told him they were trying to cure
his cancer
it ended up resulting in rapid wolverine
style regeneration powers
and he can regrow limbs he can even
reattach his head
if it is close to his neck but according
to
comic's canon if his head is detached
from his body
for 12 minutes his brain will run out of
oxygen
and he will die wolverine said if
wolverine
says that's how regeneration works then
you know it's right because that guy
knows his way around the block
that's right does it hurt right up main
street so
short answer yes deadpool can die he can
actually die in all kinds of ways
he is really just a slightly more
durable
than average human being so any way that
you can kill a durable
human you can kill deadpool just to give
some fun examples that we know from the
comics
punisher frank castle shot deadpool
right in the head
he also crushed his skull we saw
deadpool briefly go to heaven there he
was uh right in the unicorn
look at the rainbow it's like heaven's
great that's nice and then
ripped back down whoops
you weren't meant to see that carnage
tore through deadpool's midsection
it caused him to bleed out deadpool's
arteries have been ripped out
of his body he has been burned alive he
has been
shot through the brain several times and
yes he has been
decapitated many many many many many
times oh my god
it's kind of fun i could watch him die
all day
yeah i guess oh my god i can't get past
the arteries being ripped out that to me
is
yeah oh what does that mean is it like
when you hold the
weird veins out of a stalk of celery and
you just feel like you're
thinking more like like a sweater string
like you just pull a little bit and it
gets further
all of a sudden you're like oh god it's
way more than i thought also we've seen
a bit of this in the deadpool films
we've seen him die
or get close to his version of death in
all kinds of horrible ways
in deadpool 2 there was a montage where
he was like drinking drano and then
dived off the tall building
it opened with him blowing himself up
into pieces he threw himself into a
polar bear pit
as you do blood sprayed everywhere well
here is the
problem tommy or i guess you could say
here's the benefit because deadpool
doesn't stay dead after you kill him so
yes we kind of pulled a little you know
semantics trick on you there he can
die and he does briefly go to the
afterlife but he
always comes back so does that make him
immortal well i don't know it depends
how you look at immortality does it mean
that you can't die you can't leave this
plane or does that mean that you
don't fully stay in that next plane why
does this work
deadpool's kind of caught in this
in-between stage between
mortality and immortality and he has a
kind of glitch
when it comes to transitioning to the
afterlife and that
comes from deadpool's weird relationship
with death and with thanos oh yes bring
it all back to the big dog
it's all about thanos see here's the
deal in the marvel comics
death isn't just this thing it's a
cosmic entity it's a female being
and thanos is in love with her
uh clearly actually in the infinity
gauntlet comics story line that
the infinity war end game event was
based on the reason
thanos snaps half of all life from
existence is
in order to try to woo lady death yeah
i've done some crazy things to get the
attention of a woman eric i mean i've
never
wiped out half of all life in the
universe but uh you know i've
sang a few songs at karaoke which dusted
away half the room that's right
it made the entire bar disappear you
know tommy i bet you'd be real fun to
watch do karaoke
i'm always the kind of guy who goes up
after the really fun guy to do karaoke
and be like yeah crowd is warm yeah and
then i pick a song that's really awkward
to sing karaoke too
tequila and i was like oh why did i just
pick billie jean what a weird song
and they're like bring tommy back i was
like no he's gone he's in the bathroom
he's at home watching his tights that's
the second time i've used that in a new
rockstars video we have to cut
[Laughter]
where were we oh yes the uh infinity war
movie
changed thanos's motivation they kind of
removed lady death
as an entity at least so far in the
universe they base thanos's drive more
on i guess population control
a form of eco-terrorism we could call it
however now that deadpool is entering
this picture
i'm sure he's gonna have lots of jokes
first off how thanos is
very similar looking to his old buddy
cable know that's gonna come up
but from his point of view he also has
the opportunity
to bring in lady death as a character
and put himself in a love triangle with
himself lady death and thanos and that
can be
deadpool's interpretation of the
infinity war conflict even if thanos
wouldn't even acknowledge that imagine
deadpool just saying look thanos we know
that you really
did this because you're trying to win
her over and there's
no way he did he's like oh yeah you
really have a crush on him i know you
did she's hot
so this deadpool is playing the role of
like the annoying uncle at thanksgiving
that's like trying to like he's his
teenage nephew but also try to hook up
with his girlfriend
yeah yeah yeah well that's like my
uncles no uncle tommy no
wait a second wait a second well if you
ain't getting her i'm going to take her
i used to be a dancer and the reason i
bring this up is that is essentially how
it works in the comics
it's not like deadpool's participation
in this love triangle was
always part of the narrative deadpool is
a total party crasher in the same way
that he was a party crasher in the
comics he could be a party crasher to
the mcu
and say no look this is how i see things
and that's exactly how the mcu should
and probably will
bring him into it he's going to be a
meta breaking the fourth wall kind of
guy you think the studio would throw us
a bone
one that doesn't end up in my mouth who
reframes the narrative in his own
jokey satirical way but in the comics
that we're talking about deadpool
totally falls in love with lady death he
considers her his girlfriend and
she is kind of into him as well and
this pisses off thanos understandably
i mean if you're the bad boy in the
entire cinematic universe and then
someone comes in and out bad boys you
like that would be
that wouldn't reach anyone and it uh
pisses off diana so much that he curses
deadpool in a specific way so that he
cannot get anywhere near
death thus creating this kind of cosmic
loophole
in which deadpool cannot ever fully die
so essentially deadpool's immortality
comes from a
sort of metaphorical restraining order
you've been served
oh you're a jerk however we should say
in a later comic i think it's 2015
thanos closed that specific loophole he
was beating the [ __ ] out of deadpool
and he was monologuing specifically
about that past choice to restrict him
from death and
to give him eternal life and that now he
officially gives him
back the gift of death but then that
comic continues on so that he kind of
brings back deadpool with cosmic science
and necromancy
uh but either way the curse is
officially undone
so where does that leave us when it
comes to deadpool's immortality
well i i'm sure many of you have
commented in the comics that pretty much
all
comic book characters are at least
narratively immortal
[Music]
no one stays dead everyone comes back
with the
exception of the ones who like inspire
the hero's origin story so like thomas
and martha wayne
uncle ben you say everyone can die in
comics but uncle ben stays dead
right bucky bucky for a while was
considered a permanently dead character
until marvel comics brought him back and
then of course in the mcu they brought
him back as well right
marvel the predecessor of captain marvel
in the comics marvel was a cree warrior
who
died to become captain marvel and then
the later comics in 2011 rebooted that
so it's carol danvers
either way the predecessor has to die so
that the successor can
take over right however deadpool i think
carries a special distinction
both the version of the comics and the
ryan reynolds version of the films
he has a situation where his function to
his world
is completely divorced from the stakes
of life and death
that govern everyone else wow enjoy hell
swamp mouth deadpool isn't really a
living breathing human character even
though we do
relate with him he does have moments
that can make you tear up
but he is a meta cartoon that is
designed
chiefly to comment and satirize his
universe
so that ultra violence that we see his
body enduring is all part of that parody
it is an element of his character that
he must die he is like
wiley coyote he's gonna die again and
again and again and john tucker he must
die where are my big tucker heads here
racist trees oh we don't want those
tucker heads get those tucker heads out
of here
we've done stories about ufos yeah
that's true i call them pity talks
the whole point of his repeated deaths
and extreme injuries
is so that the reader and the viewer is
desensitized
to those deaths so that we can just get
past that part of it
and instead appreciate whatever else
he's trying to accomplish
his repeated death is in a way a kind of
commentary on how
in comics over the decades characters
die
all the time and are just brought back
i'm back [ __ ]
yeah deadpool is the living embodiment
of that commentary on how
goofy and ridiculous that is so when it
comes to how we're going to see him in
the mcu
i expect the mcu at first to
maintain the immortality curse can be
done in a couple different ways maybe
they can just use infinity stone logic
because that tends to be how they just
justify all kinds of things
where's my eyebrows where's my focus
it's a stone
we know that the infinity war
screenwriters wanted to bring in
the cosmic universal judge the living
tribunal there was going to be a
trial where doctor strange dragged
thanos in front of the living tribunal
and the living tribunal judged him
guilty
during their whole wizard duel that
ended up not being the case there is a
staff of the living tribunal in the
doctor strange artifacts collection
but it's a there's enough there to say
the living tribunal that judge exists
somewhere in the cosmos maybe deadpool
as a result of all his crimes gets some
kind of a plea
deal with the living tribunal where he
has to exist in this new universe but he
can only die a certain number of times
or something like that
sure like a video game give him five
mario style the
simplest way is to just go the same
route as it is in the comics make
death lady death a corporeal or at least
existing
personified goddess in this universe and
while it seems a little crazy to go
there right now deadpool is himself
crazy enough to where if you just put
him in that conversation and then plop
him into the mcu
we're gonna go along with it now there
were some theories that meredith
quill that was peter quill's mother
could be lady death that that might be
the big easter egg that james gunn
was hiding in guardians of the galaxy
that would pose some hilarious spats
between star-lord
and deadpool just imagine chris pratt
and ryan reynolds screaming at each
other
super penis but for
now at least james gunn has i think shot
down
the exact terms of that meredith quill
lady death theory
however he has also hinted at that we
have gotten
very very close with our various
interpretations of meredith quill
there is something to meredith quill and
it might not be lady death it might not
be eternity
it might not be the other figures that
we've talked about but there is some
secret with her that james gunn
is brewing reveal your secrets
so as we wait to find out exactly how
deadpool will fit in the mcu
and how unkillable he will be i will
just say that
all the pieces are in place to justify
it as closely to the marvel comics
without weirding us out too much
but delivering a ton of laughs along the
way so
in conclusion deadpool is immortal but
not
unkillable okay and that might change
when he enters the mcu
ah well that makes i can kind of wrap my
brain around that he's immortal but he's
not unkillable
so he can have a lot of fun in between
spats of immortality
i'm touching myself tonight and that's
what makes them fun that's why we love
him
all right uh let's uh thank some friends
who helped us make this episode starting
with our friends at expressvpn
so earlier this year more than 100
high-profile twitter users got their
accounts
hacked we're talking passwords email
address phone numbers
and more were all taken from people like
joe biden
elon musk kanye west those kinds of
attacks are gonna get more frequent and
severe it's a brave new world that we
live in and
unfortunately it's not just twitter
facebook ebay uber all these things
have leaked the credit card info of
billions of users
look if someone can hack elon musk
imagine how easy it is to hack
you that is why we use expressvpn to
safeguard our personal data online
according to recent reports hackers can
make up to one thousand dollars from
selling someone's personal information
on the dark web
making people like me and you lucrative
targets
expressvpn is an app that funnels your
data through secure
cryptid tunnel no matter what device you
use you can have peace of mind every
time you use the internet
the app connects with just one click it
is lightning fast and the best part is
expressvpn works on up to five devices
simultaneously so you
and your whole family can stay protected
if a breach can happen to powerful
individuals
it can easily happen to you so protect
yourself with
expressvpn the vpn rated number one by
cnet and wired
and if you visit expressvpn.com bigq
right now you can arm yourself with an
extra three
months of expressvpn for free that is
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
bigq visit expressvpn.comq to learn more
we also want to thank our friends at
doordash for helping us make this
episode deadpool might have unlimited
time but you do not
save time give yourself one less thing
to worry about and let doordash take
care of your next meal doordash is the
app that brings you food you are craving
right now right to your door
ordering is easy you just open the
doordash app you choose what you want to
eat and your food will be left safely
outside your door
with a new contactless delivery drop-off
setting with over 300
000 partners in the u.s and puerto rico
canada australia
you can choose from your favorite
national restaurants like chipotle
or wendy's in the cheesecake factory
many of your favorite local restaurants
are still open for delivery just open
the door dash app select your favorite
local restaurant and your food will be
left at your door
doordash deliveries are now contactless
to keep the communities we operate and
safe
right now our listeners can get five
dollars off and zero delivery fees on
their first order of fifteen dollars or
more
when you download the door dash app and
enter the code big question
that's five dollars off and zero
delivery fees on your first order when
you download the door dash app and the
app store and answer the code
big question don't forget let's go to
big question for five dollars off your
first order with doordash
all right now comes the time for a
bite-sized question that tommy and i are
going to try to chow
down on i don't know why i said it that
way i feel worse
okay i'm gonna go with it i'm gonna lean
into that yeah andy bonanni
nrpi a good friend of ours on discord
asks is it possible to break a
lightsaber blade
in half so glad you asked danny badani
let's talk about what a lightsaber hilt
is damaged the blade
shuts off and stops working we saw this
when obi-wan sliced off maul's saber and
phantom menace of course or when
anakin's lightsaber was damaged by the
genocis
machinery in the last jedi kylo and ray
both tried to force pull
luke's lightsaber in opposite directions
goes against a split in a flash of light
the lightsaber was broken and ray
later repaired it like a true crafty
latchkey kid with too much time and no
parental supervision
and a lot of duct tape however in this
case i think we can assume that the
question is asking if the lightsaber
blade could be split vertically or down
the shaft of the laser blade like
slicing a hot dog the long way
creating two delicious hot dogs no two
droopy
thinner lightsaber noodles two littles
as i call them in order to answer soon
the look under the hood of the
engineering of a lightsaber something we
actually
do know quite a bit about a lightsaber
house is a crystal chamber which
contains
kyber crystals these power the
lightsabers given its color and are
unique to the jedi or sith who built the
saber energy from these crystals is
harnessed via a generator converting it
to plasma
closer to the tip of the hilt is a
magnetic field emitter this releases a
magnetic field that contains the flow of
energy from the crystals which takes the
form of a tightly looped arc of plasma
the plasma passes through the magnetic
stabilizing ring this is what actually
shapes the blade
and holds the plasma in place okay so
when we
when the lightsaber's emitted that sound
that it makes is actually
plasma spewing out of the tip of this
thing but it is held in place by this uh
right magnetic field emitters baby you
gotta have them i got one on my chevy
cruze another lightsaber or bhaskar
weapon could not split the magnetic
field itself they repel a lightsaber
blade just by counteracting that
magnetic field
it's not like one jousting pole
splintering another jousting pole you
know you're just gonna
it's not like two hot dogs hitting each
other what am i doing
like this is terrible what i'm doing
so i like to blur that out it's not like
this but it's a lot of fun uh
okay however if you were to damage that
however if you were to damage the
magnetic stabilizing ring that would
rupture the control of the shape of the
energy emission
the magnetic field would be removed but
the plasma would still stream out
blasting extreme
heat in all directions melting the
lightsaber handle itself and destroying
the crystal chamber
and generator until the process stops it
is incredible
that we have this much scientific
information on a fictional weapon
it's really scary people build their own
lightsabers
hacksmith on youtube you can see they
built one and put it through like some
metal it was crazy the only thing
keeping
us from destroying ourselves are the
existence of kyber crystals if they
exist in the real world people would be
yup ready to go final piece oh my god
everyone instead of like backyard
wrestling injuries there'd be people
that were just saw it in half during
like amateur lightsaber exhibitions
so to answer the question no you cannot
cleanly split a lightsaber in half but
you can bust one up so bad that everyone
in the room burns alive so
yeah win-win i guess that makes sense
right
what you're hitting is like a beam of
plasma that's held in place by a magnet
you can't
split that beam in half you can just
like break it so that it all spills
everywhere right but it's not like the
old
way i assume that's her asking right
like if you're split it in half that's
that's where it goes it can't do that
you can't it's hard to do that even with
metal swords
right which is good because otherwise it
would just be fantasia brooms all over
the place and then
people just keep splitting lightsabers
in half too many lightsabers
and then there's me and my mickey robes
just conducting stop conducting tommy
i can't keep it it's the artist in me
it's catchy
all right uh we have time for one final
box of scraps
questions staying on the theme of
deadpool's immortality yes
have you ever had a near-death
experience that made you realize that
you weren't immortal
i have uh and it happened to me when i
was like 14 years old which i think is
the age when you are almost
the most immortal in your mind i used to
get really bad strep throat
and like throat infections so the doctor
was like you got to get your tonsils out
so i was like yeah sure okay my mom said
we should do this so they were like you
know it's very safe there's like a
little chance that it won't heal because
what they do is they just snip them out
and then they let them kind of heal they
don't stitch them
automatically there's a pain in the neck
to do that so they're like we'll take
them out and then if you have any
problems you know we can come in and
stitch them up later but it should be
fine totally fine
so they take them out and that goes fine
you know obviously i wake up groggy with
a sore throat for a couple of days so
i'm home recovering
i should say the next two minutes of
this story are going to get very gross
did i get any in my mouth your squeamish
it's fast forward to this thank you for
the warning
so i get up one morning and i have kind
of what it feels like just like a lump
in my throat so i go
to the bathroom and i cough up
like what i just thought was like some
some phlegm and i proceeded to do that
like five or six more times throughout
the
the morning just these like getting
these just like it's like i thought i
was like congested so finally at like
two in the afternoon i go in and cough
up
another what i thought was a flim ball
and just
exorcist projectile vomit blood all over
the mirror
uh what i had been coughing up were
blood clots from the where the thing in
my
throat was supposed to be healing and i
was just hemorrhaging blood uh
so oh my god my mom called my mom in and
i was very scared and we went to the
emergency room
and they were like yeah go ahead and get
in line and i just at the time when they
were just gonna like cast me inside the
emergency room i just happened to like
throw up again into a towel and they
were like
okay get him into get him into a room so
so so what had happened is the artery
had ruptured in the back of my throat
and the doctor came in and he had to
stick a biggest syringe i've ever seen
in my life in the back to just paralyze
the artery so it would stop bleeding
so they could then figure out what to do
no i'm 14 and have like zero
idea of like i just think i'm like i'm
like this is unfortunate but at no point
am i
scared until i look at my mom who is
just like
i've never seen more terrified in my
life and she just looks at me and goes
just don't die you can have whatever you
want and in my 14 year old wisdom i said
i want to be able to watch monday night
raw and that's the bottom line
because stonko said so
you're like brendan dassey like can i
get out in time for wrestlemania
i mean i could have been like a mustang
in two years when i could drive but i
was like
no more harassing me when i want to
watch the undertaker
so you know the ultimately science did
its job and the the artery was paralyzed
and they went in
stitched it up and i spent the next like
year and a half of my life
thinking it was gonna happen again like
i constantly
would have like phantom things in my
throat being like oh it's gonna rupture
again and it never did
uh yet knock on wood but yeah that was
my uh that was my
near-death experience the aftermath was
like i
couldn't stand up for a couple weeks i
lost so much blood they said because i
was so young they didn't have to give me
a transfusion because i could
reject i could make the blood back it
took a long time so i was like bedridden
for like a month
oh my god so that made me understand
that human beings are fragile
wow tommy i i should have gone first
yours is insane
that's like a sam raimi horror freak
show moment there
i would be terrified of 14 years old
hemorrhaging blood all over the mirror
good lord
okay uh my mine wasn't anywhere near as
close to death as yours
it was just like the first time i had
that switch and being like i'm gonna
live forever
and then like i'm a broken baby
uh i was 13 years old and i did karate
as a kid
tell me i don't know if you knew this i
am technically a black belt
in an offshoot of a taekwondo called
tongsudo it's like a
it's another korean kind of aerobic
martial art
oh my god that's awesome i am
but anyone can destroy me if i face it
in battle i have not been practicing it
i was i was not good at riding a bike
you'll get it back there was like two
and a half years where i was extremely
disciplined in this and this is where it
all came to an end
okay so uh my brother who's seven years
older than me we would wrestle a lot and
i
started to feel like i picked up some
moves we both know i'm trying to become
a cage fighter i knew how to sweep the
leg
yeah i could take him out i i could
stand up with him
but he was like twice my body weight he
was working out a lot in college
he was in he was in good shape to take
me down and he was trying to watch march
madness on
tv sure and he was about to go back to
school he was
home with us that week and he's about to
drive back to college he's just trying
to watch
fsu play in the march madness game i go
oh matt are you
watching this game oh this game and i
stood in front of the tv and i just
started to shake my butt and i'm like oh
am i
in your way it was probably like you
know 12 seconds left on the clock of
course i really timed it
and i was like oh i'm sorry are you
trying to watch
this and he's like eric if you don't get
out of the way of the tv i'm gonna drop
you and i'm like
i'd like to see you try yeah
i thought i could take him so come down
here and see what happens if you try and
hit me
and he's like okay uh and he started to
stand up and i had like a big glass of
milk and i'm like no no no man i'm sorry
i was like i'm gonna smell my milk and i
kind of just wanted to wrestle with him
before he went back
and then he totally dropped me and i
fell in a specific way oh i landed on
the ground my
shoulder and my head hit the ground at
the same time
popping my clavicle i broke my
collarbone oh no
one of the most painful bones you can
break oh god no oh
yeah they've never broken a bone before
yeah that's a tough one to be your first
break i'll tell you that much
oh my god and i laid on the ground
screaming my brother was freaked out
like
i killed what have i done what have i
done
and i was like you killed me matt you
killed me you ruined my life
i will have my revenge
[Laughter]
but uh i was supposed to test for
whatever the next belt was that weekend
oh no i didn't i missed the test so i
was out and i had to go to school when
you break your collarbone i don't know
if they have a better sling now
you have to wear the weirdest looking
sling oh yeah where there's like a strap
that goes up here there's yeah that goes
around there's like another trap you
look like you're in half a straight
jacket
i don't think that that has improved i
think that that it's like a almost like
a cape weirdly isn't it oh
sure yeah there's like a weird yeah it's
a bit of a phantom of the opera effect
don't look at me but they give you that
and uh they they do it because the
clavicle's so weird the way it's
positioned and you have to have like
downward pressure
to make sure the bone heals correctly i
went from being such like a little
badass that was completely undeserved
to feeling like no one touched me people
need to help me carry my textbooks
and i almost got addicted to vicodin oh
god
second twist i i forgot that this is
part of the story oh my god
so they they prescribed me you know
because you can get over the counter
motrin and
if you could still get over the counter
motion that stuff's powerful enough they
gave me a bit of vicodin because you
would wake up in the middle of the night
and when your body shifts in tremendous
pain so like just pop a vicodin
so i would wake up at three in the
morning screaming
it would like reach for the vicodin and
then like pop
up pop in a couple pills and then i ran
out of the bottle and i was like
mother i need to refill this
prescription she's working i gotta get
more of this stuff
this is the second you're 13 years old
and i was like but i knew that
i got so violently enraged and i was
like i would wake up now i'm like the
motrin has it strong enough
to scream at night because that vicodin
man that you're out like a light
and ever since then i finished out
whatever the next belt was and then i
i stopped doing karate from there
forward and i have never been in the
fist fight
even counting the moment out of my wimpy
rage i i swung
at philip one time on a road trip that
was good and then i'm here
you got this
i did not say you got this i've wanted
to swing at philip before don't worry
about it that's yeah
well it's only on road trips he likes to
pester you while you're driving
and then you're not even in control of
yourself you just turn into a monster
i'm gonna get a text from philip when
did you want to swing at me
never father never it was a joke i was
just trying to fit in
eric one thing i one thing your story
tells me is that you are
ready for your narrative arc on the
fourth season of cobra kai would you
come in
and redeem yourself and then immediately
break my collarbone again eric voss was
the hottest martial artist in florida
until a clavicle took him down and now
he's back to take on the cobra kai
oh that's gonna be me ah yeah that's me
caspian cobra kai that'd be great
well none of us are immortal and neither
is this show because that is it for this
episode of the big question
what a fun time this has been i learned
so much about you tommy from that too
much
my heart goes out for you as a younger
man thank god we all recovered eh
your clavicle's fine my throat is golden
never got any complaints about my throat
trust
me
[Laughter]
yeah well tommy it has been fun uh
jordan knew this episode
oh [ __ ] follow tommy and tommy bechtold
follow
me at ea vos uh be sure to follow new
rockstars and socials you can send us
your big questions using the hashtag
bigquestion you can also subscribe to
this podcast feed
wherever you get your podcast leave us a
nice reading review if you don't mind
subscribe to new rockstars here on
youtube get that notification bell and
uh we will see you next time
stay safe everyone
[Music]
you